hey guys ryan right over here yeah and
i'm gerry on just this side today yeah
yeah because i figure you know and
you're thin the thumbnail they'll see
you oh yeah they'll be like what's this
guy doing mmhmm yeah we should switch
she thought I just realized the whole
thumbnail thing because I should I
deserve all the attention people wanted
us to talk about this I'm not sure why I
have so many opinions hey Jesse
Eisenberg as Lex Luthor and they
released an image of him bald yes he is
bald he looks bald they released an
image confirming that ya know he still
is playing like yeah you know what lex
luthor looks like now he looks like that
i mean i guess you can grasp a lot more
of the character from it like if you
really like look into the photo I mean
he looks like know you could see like a
hurt angry person inside of him he does
like villainous you could see a guy who
totally wants to destroy Superman in
this guy's face and another thing it was
actually a lot more to say about it's
clearly they've done an all right
casting j yeah because people were
really doubting Jesse Eisenberg like he
was we was a major down you know the
thing is though is that I feel like
people were doubting Jesse Eisenberg
like because of his hair yeah like the
second you see in with a shaved head out
I was thinking that before when people
like Jesse Eisenberg I was like the
second they release a photo like this
one people are gonna go oh they're
shaved hey I guess you know Jesse
Eisenberg's are really good active and I
mean I don't know if he's gonna you know
stretch his acting ability for this but
I can see not just as a big lex luthor
being a bit you know neurotic if he's
like a brilliant mind he owns you oh
yeah he was the head of Lex corp and
he's obsessive and stuff like that like
I can see him with a little bit of that
Jesse Eisenberg neurosis I don't know if
my eyes are just playing a trick on me
but this is left I look bigger yeah a
little bit it's a little more open but a
lot of people's eyes with so it's just
enough it's just a regular I thing it's
not like a special i think or maybe I
doesn't like me to see the optometrist
or something like I get the the thing
that people are probably upset about
because he's played a lot of young
people
played a lot of like awkward teenage
roles but I feel like you know you get
the social network where he's kind of
getting into a more he's still like a
young person but he's getting into a
more like bold and abrasive characters I
feel like we haven't seen the kind of
performance he will give for Lex Luthor
yet but we will when he does that
hopefully when I find interesting about
some of the casting you know like when
we saw the Dark Knight trilogy they were
casting actors for roles where you're
like that guy is a transformation yeah
you know like Gary Oldman into
Commissioner Gordon and Christian Bale
and a Batman Heath Ledger Joker you know
how it goes yeah Tom Hardy made that
dude from red eye kelly murphy Liam
Murphy did it won't kill it don't even
he's my boy they cast Ben Affleck in the
cast Jesse Eisenberg they're not known
to like really change up a whole lot
yeah you know so that's not character
people as money yeah it's like okay
that's Ben Affleck with different
emotions he's playing yeah you know and
that same thing with jesse eisenberg but
they don't really change up their speech
pattern they don't really change up
their body language that's where I
thought like okay it's gonna be hard not
to see Jesse Eisenberg as much as like
people thought I'd be difficult not to
see Ben Affleck we don't know yet but
this looks like I can't believe I'm not
used to seeing a bald at least the thing
that gives me a little hope for a Ben
Affleck Batman's I can see him doing a
Bruce Wayne and then Batman he's got all
the costuming and voice modulation yeah
whereas Eisenberg he's just got a suit
and a not haircut you know he looks like
right no Jesse Heisenberg hello Jesse
Jesse we have to cook jesse hart
Sandberg he is both he's like young
Walter White Walter why I was doing it
when he was young anyway guys thanks for
tuning in to hear our opinions on this
photograph today if you're new to the
channel you can subscribe to the real
rejects to it jerry has a playlist on
this channel reasons to jerry their
reasons you can follow both of us on
Facebook Instagram and Twitter that's
right because we like followers yeah we
want more because for our cult yeah
we're we're starting a cult
reaction cult a repack speak up